[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
comprehensive solutions for your t-reg
mouse and human research
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by miltenny biotech
to learn more visit
meltineybiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
our speaker will answer questions via
email to the address you provided during
registration
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr nilo farr mon jossery global product
manager for t-cell immunology melting
biotech
dr manhasseri you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone my name is nilu farmon
hasseri i'm the product manager for
immunology t-cells at milton biotech and
in
this webinar for today i'm going to
explain you how to translate a turret
research workflow to clinical grade
manufacturing
so let's start
the agenda for today first of all i
would like to give you an introduction
about miltoni biotech and then talking
about t-rex
and then following the webinar by
talking about turveg research workflow
and then to a clinical grade workflow
and
end up to the summary and final remarks
miltoni biotech was founded at
1989 in germany
we are more than 3 500 employees all
over the world from more than 50
nationalities
and 25 percent of our employee are
barking at r d
and we are reported in more than uh
46 000 scientific references
we have more than
17 000 products and presents in more
than
a hundred thousand cell therapy
procedures and also
approximately six thousand patients
treated with cell products using our
technologies and uh
we have
sales direct sales in 23 countries and
we are transporting our products to more
than 73 countries as well
miltoni biotech is empowering discovery
and advancing therapy our mission is to
advance scientific research and medicine
by providing solutions for curative cell
and gene therapy as well as biomedical
research
we have wide variety of product
portfolio and our products are from
research to clinical applications
in miltoni biotech we are covering
different topics such as immunology
cancer research stem cell research
cardiovascular research and neuroscience
and at the same time in the clinical
side we have very great uh portfolio for
graft engineering immune therapy and
also regenerative medicine
okay let's start with some introduction
about terek translating turek research
to clinical application
regulatory t-cells 2x are very important
subset of t cells and they have three
main functions the first one is
suppression of overwhelming immune
responses which keep the balance and
homostasis in the body the second
important functions
is suppression of immune responses
against self-antigens and non-self
antigens which protect against
autoimmunity and mediate the tolerance
in the body and the third functionality
of two eggs is suppression of
anti-cancer immune responses which
support the tumor growth and it's a
functionality that needed to be
considered especially during the
cancer treatment as um
two eggs in this area are supporting the
tumor growth and their functionality
needed to be controlled actually
and
recognition of the regulatory t-cells as
you might know t-rex are not expressing
any unique like surface markers they can
be recognized or phenotypes by fun by a
combination of the surface markers such
as cd4 cd25 lack of cd127 or
cd45r
and so on and the uh very important
intra cellular markers it's fox p3
that
expression of this transcription shows
the functionality of this the t-rex and
also according to their
origin of this
t-rex they can subdivide it in three
groups naive t-rex peripheral t-rex and
in vitro 2x
two eggs can build studies in different
research and clinical fields and
in different indications like
transplantation inflammation allergy
cancer gvhd autoimmune disease pregnancy
and so on but why two eggs has really
like key roles in the body because as
you can see in this illustration there
is a balance between two regulatory
cells and t effector cells in a
situation that the body is in a healthy
condition
but in some circumstances this balance
is disturbed and two egg therapy
is going to uh
really like protect this balance and
then retain this balance so by expanding
the two eggs and infusion to the patient
they try to keep this balance again
re-establish this balance again let's
say
so it's the reason that 2-ectropy is an
important part of adaptive immune
therapy and t-cell therapy
and for
all these research areas and clinical
studies
you need to have good and optimized
workflow in the research side and in the
clinical side and it's our mission to
provide enough tools for you to achieve
your goals
so let's go one step further and have a
look at t-reg research workflow at
melting biotech
t-reg workflow consists of different
steps
sample preparation cell separation
expansion and cell analysis
and as i've mentioned at the beginning
of my talk at miltoni we are offering
translational workflows and 2x is one of
the topic that we are covering
completely translational workflow
from research products which i'm gonna
show in orange color that's our sort of
products for human mouse and non-private
and as you can see in this uh photo or
slides we cover all these steps of a
workflow
and at the same time we have some sort
of gmp products that cover the clinical
workflow i'm going to talk about each
steps
in the following slides
okay let's start with research portfolio
and the first step is sample preparation
for getting a very good result out of
your whole experiment you need to
optimize your sample preparation
the main resources of two eggs in mouse
are spleen and lymph node and also it
can be isolated from tumor and other
various tissue
and
in human
we can isolate two eggs mainly from
pbmcs directly from blood blood and also
from tumor and other tissues but in the
sample preparation platform
um
we are focusing on the uh tumor and
tissue
material and
gentle max dissociator
big family
tissue dissociation kits and all the
solutions that you need to
store your cells remove your dead cells
and different type of tubes and also
strainers and filters that can help you
to get a very high quality
cell suspension with high viability
are available in our
sample preparation platform
i'm pretty sure that many of you know
about gentlemax but i really want to
emphasize on this great device and tell
you that it is really like i always say
that it is the heart of the sample
preparation part because it provides a
standardized tissue dissociation and
you really save your samples as the
dissociation can be done in closed
system and it's one instrument for both
cellular and molecular applications and
there are some optimized protocol for
the most frequently used tissue and at
the same time customized programming for
any type of tissue is possible in this
device and we offering you comprehensive
kits for enzymatic treatments that is
adopted and addressed in this device as
well
and
we are offering elaborate strainers and
filters to get a single cell suspension
and remove the debris and sell clumps
and all and all ended to very high
quality with high viability of single
cell suspension
let's have a look at the
application example that was done with
one of our customers they use a
gentlemax dissociator and also um gentle
maxi tube
besides using 70 micrometers smarter
strainer
and then they try to
dissociate the mouse dorsal skin which
is a hard tissue to
uh dissociate and then they identified
fox p3 positive regulatory t cells as
you can see here the total number of
these cells
was compared with manual protocol and
gentle max protocol in gentle max
protocol you see that you have less
variation
and in the next graph you can see the
reasonable and really like high
difference between the cd4 positive fox
p3 positive two eggs out of gentle max
in comparison to
manual protocol which shows the good
efficiency of this device and
combination of the products to
dissociate the tissue and also in this
uh
right hand side you can see the fox p3
cells which were analyzed with fellow
cytometry that's
the gentlemax protocol show the higher
cell number of pox p3 positive cells
compared to the manual protocol
okay the next step t-reg isolation you
need to choose the best strategy to
isolate your t-rex at miltoni biotech we
offer you wide variety of products and i
know that sometimes you say
which one is really fitting to our
workflow and how can i get a high purity
high
uh let's say recovery and so on and so
on and some of you have very like a
specific needs in your workflow but i
can tell you they have the max cell
separation magnetic separation
technology that offers you different
type of
like kits
and we offer different and wide variety
of the devices from very manual devices
to fully automated robotic integration
devices
and beside all these separation kits
we are going to offer you t-rex starting
with our unique max quan title cell
sorters i'm going to talk about each of
these options step by step
here you are max cell separation select
the best we are offering you wide
variety of products for example
for positive selection which is really
ideal for rare cells and hard to process
tissues
or untouched selection with isolation
kits that is really like
a good approach for pre-enrichment
before fellow analysis or subsequent
positive selection or max express
solutions for really being fast and easy
and convenient and at the same time you
can scale cell separation according to
your needs you can benefit from
completely manual approaches or benefit
from multi-max x for fully automated
system
in maxwell separation columns are a
technological advantage max column
amplifies the magnetic field by 10 000
times
and the cells get minimal labeling with
nano size microbeads and also cells
friendly hydrophilic coating
and large space between steel spheres in
column metrics are provided
and then you will enrich yourselves
without any uh on a specific activation
the cells has like free epitopes for
downstream uh compatibility
and also there is no bit um aggregation
as you can see in the picture as well
and this method is can be easily
translated to um clinic and it can be
scalable and automatable according to
your needs and also uh this technology
is used in clinical researchers for cell
manufacturing in in more than 55 000
patients and it is approved by fda
at miltoni biotech we are offering you a
wide variety of products for isolating
your t-rex i know that sometimes it
makes it really difficult for you to
choose the best kit and a strategy for
isolating your cells so please stay with
me i'm going to explain you about all
the strategy then you can choose the
best one for your research
first of all i would like to start with
max express t-rex isolation kits which
enable you to isolate your t-rex
directly from the whole blood
max express t-rex isolation kit helps
you to isolate your t-rex directly from
blood
in this approach your cells get labeled
and then depletion of non-cd4 positive
cells can be done and it followed by
taking the supernatants and then
positive selection for cd25 can happen
and at the end the cells can be eluted
uh in the final buffer so in this
approach you will isolate your two eggs
just in 30 minutes which is quite fast
the current solution other kids takes
longer than 90 minutes
and then you will get a excellent purity
of these cells as you can see here 90
percent cd4 cd25 positive cells and over
60 percent fox p3 cells
and also the recovery uh out of this kit
is quite good so t-rex can be isolated
from whole blood without phycol
and it's one of the options for the
teams that's
time is a real matter for them they want
to get the best purity and recovery in a
very short time
let's continue with other kids that's uh
help you to isolate your t-rex from pbmc
some of them are just for humans some of
them for human and mice let's have a
look in the next slide you will see that
how efficient each of them are working
and how they fit in your
workflow
all the t-rex isolation kits based on
two steps depletion of unwanted cells
and positive selection
and i put here cd4 cd25 positive tuberc
isolation kit as an example in the first
step
i actually the depletion of unwanted
non-cd4 positive cell can be done and
you will have untouched target cells and
in the next step you will have the
positive selection of cd
um 25 positive cells
as you can see here's
the untouched cells get labeled and then
they pass through to the magnet and then
the captured cells can be eluted to the
final buffer and you will have your
final cd4 city 25 positive 2xls
okay let's have a look at this busy
slide the first question is what do you
need you really need to understand your
application and why do you need your
t-rex and what is your down-stream
application when you can answer this
question then you can have a look at the
different kits and then the different
purity that you can get from each kids
and also the recovery out of each kids
for example if you are going for highest
purity of the fox p3 positive cells like
up to 96 percents and isolate your naive
two eggs i would
uh advise you to use cd4 cd25 cd127
theme kids
or if you are really going for
isolation of naive t-rex but you want to
expand them in long-term in vitro so i
would suggest you to use cd4 city cd49
negative turret isolation kits
so as i've mentioned first of all we
need to understand why do you need your
t-rex what is your downstream
application and then we can help you to
choose the best strategy and the best
kit for your workflow
okay in this slide i put some data for
you that i know that you will like it it
shows the functionality of cd4 cd25
positive
cd127 team negative turret isolation
kits
the uh
fellow analysis shows that we can reach
over 92 percent cd4 cd25 positive cells
and also over 90 percent of cd4 cd25
positive cd100 2017 negative cells and
in the negative fraction you will see
that the
ratio of the
cd4 city 45 racd 127 dim negative cells
is not that much high and it's uh to be
honest it's
one of my favorite isolation kits that
helps you to really reach high purity
with a very good recovery
and also enables you to isolate your
naive t-rex that
you can expand for a long time in the
culture as well
two eggs can be isolated via cell sorter
as well
and here i would like to use this
opportunity to talk about max quantile
cell sorter many of you are already in
the t-rex field and know about this
great device as it is a translational
device and you can use it in research on
clinical sites it's just one aspect of
this device but this device is quite
gentle to the cells then it helps you to
reach high viability of the cells it
contains three lasers for up to 10
optical parameters and also it's fully
enclosed disposable cartridge for sample
as reality and operator system and you
will get a very great viable cells that
enables you to go for whatever
downstream application that you need
maxquan title cartridges are an
important component of this system they
have three chambers input chambers
positive selection chambers and negative
collection chambers
in the positive collection chambers you
will get your positive fraction any
negative collection chamber you will
have the negative
uh let's say um
sort of cells and then in the negative
fraction you can even use them for the
second round of
selection and as you can see the
microchip is located here on the bottom
of the cartridge and you can see the
size of this microchip which is quite a
small
and also the maximum volumes for the
input is 10 milliliter positive
collection chamber
can contain two milliliters and then
negative collection chambers
uh 10 milliliter and as you can see here
this sorting this wall is um
it's the wall that just uh direct the
negative fraction to the negative
chamber and positive um fraction to the
positive chamber and here are located
these three lasers that help the cells
to be sorted
accordingly
in this slides you can see an example of
sorking of memory t-rex
to get the memory t-works we stained the
cells with cd4 cd25 cd127
cd45r0 and cd45ra
fluorescence colors and then we sorted
the cells and the target cells you can
see for cd4 positive cd24 25 positive
cells will reach up to uh sorry over to
95 percent
and uh like not if two eggs will reach
like 97 percent and the memory t-rex um
fraction is really great number like
over 98 percent uh purity and it shows
the functionality of these
this cell searcher for sorting even like
the very very rare cells with the
highest purity that you can get
t-rex expansion i know that this step
can be very challenging but with
choosing the best component for your
tourette culturing you can optimize this
step maxwell
culture media
offering utex max medium which is a
special medium for
expansion of t cells and also t-rex they
are free of animal drive components they
are offering optimal cell growth
reliable actuation and also
are available with or without fennel
reds and uh they are available up to gmp
qualities especially um attractive for
the teams that has like translational
plan to translate their research studies
to their clinical studies the second
component is the choosing the good
cytokines we offer you max cytokines and
premium grade which has improved
sequence that offer you better
reconstitution and increase stability
and activity in the culture and also
they are available for human and mouse
cell stimulation
they give you a lot of specific
biological activity and also they are
available up to gmp quality
the next component is expansion kits
which uh help you to simulate your 2x to
get the best
let's say expansion they have these
expansion kits for human and mouse and
also these expansion kits are available
to gmp quality
in this slide i would like to show you
with some data the efficacy of this
components all together
uh okay we decided to isolate the t-rex
with different isolation kits and we did
that and then we cultured the cells in
tex-max medium in the presence of il-2
premium grade drapomycin and simulation
kits or expansion turret kits and i just
decided to show you the expansion rate
of the two eggs out of max express t-rex
isolation kits
after 14 days we reach 22 times
expansion
and after 21 day we reach 40
times expansion rate which is a great
number but it is not the end of the
story your cells need it to be really
functional cells
you can test the functionality of your
cells with some like um functional
assays but at the same time it's really
important to check for the expression of
fox p3 to get the most inhibitory cells
in your final yield and as you can see
here over 67 percent of the expanded
cells are positive for fox p3 cells
which is a great uh results
okay at this point i want to stop with
talking about turek research workflow
and wants to start uh with the tuereg
clinical grade workflow and at the end
of this step i'm going to talk about
cell analysis as well because the cell
analysis or t-reg analysis platform for
a t-reg research workflow and to a
clinical workflow is more or less
similar then i would talk about it at
the end of the turret clinical grade
workflow
i hope that you can remember this slide
as i've mentioned we are a translational
company and we have solutions for the
research studies and clinical studies we
already covered the research side but as
i've mentioned i'm going to talk about
cell analysis at the end
and then i want to start with the um
clinical grade 2 egg manufacturing and
our solutions for you so let's start
there are three main steps for clinical
t-reg manufacturing t-reg isolation
turret expansion and turret analysis and
as you can see here i've sorted all the
needed material that you might need for
producing clinical grade t-rex
i'm going to talk about each step in the
following
slides for clinical grade turret
manufacturing we are offering you to
workflow but these two workflows are
different just in two-way isolation step
in the fork flow one you can see that
clinimax plus is the main device that
you can deplete cd8 and cd19 cells and
also enrich the cd25 cells and this
step can be followed by cell sorting
with a max quantitative cell sorter that
for getting a higher purity even
but in workflow 2 we have cleaning max
prodigy lp 25 process which consists of
three steps enrichments of cd25 cells
labeling the two eggs with
fluorochromes and elute the t-rex
entitle
cell sorter buffers and then the cells
pass through the to the max quantity
cell sorter for reaching the very high
purity cells
okay i would like to give you more info
about this part as i know this step is
really like challenging for lots of you
and you know and you're very like
interested to know more about it
workflow one which is a t-rex isolation
with cleaning max plus
uh it's a specifically a proper
approach for producing cells for for
example gvhd prevention and treatments
and suitable for the application that we
need to reach intermediate to high
purity
and you can reach like uh less than 96
percent 2x and these manufacturing times
um or better to say the isolation steps
takes seven hours
and you can expand your cells according
to your application from 12 to 36
days but there are difference like a
workflow different approaches that you
need to see which approach and which
method for expansion of your cells is
fitting
best to your application
and final cell numbers depending on the
donor and the expansion time
absolutely it's the first but we expect
to get like 50 to 1000 times expansion
as i've already mentioned in clinimax
plus
you can deplete your cells uh cd8 and
cd19 cells and also enrich cd25 cells
and we have all the reagents in gmp
grade
and afterwards it can be followed by
cell sorting to get a higher purity
but in these um
graphs you can see that you can reach
like over 92 persons purity or target
cell city 25 positive city 127 team
okay cleaning max
plus device offers you
different aspects like convenient
isolation process
very high recovery high cell number
yield
and maintenance of t-rex phenotype
maintenance maintenance of turret
function and also polyclonal isolation
and we have a reference list as well
that you can use and see which teams are
using this system and how efficient it's
working but what is interesting at this
point
is that there are two main
questions in the field right now that
how to isolate different 2x subsets or
antigen specific qx and how to reach the
ultra purity 2x because of some
application right now in the market that
many of you need to really reach ultra
pure 2x cells and at the same time
isolate your
antigen specific 2 eggs or very rare 2x
subsets so what is our solution for this
step
okay the challenges in the market naive
t-rex is a small cell population and i
know that many of you need to isolate
the naive t-rex for downstream
applications ultra pure t-rex is another
challenge that um
lots there are lots of like opportunity
for starting the cells but they are
quite stressful for the cells and as
i've mentioned at the beginning of my
talk tear eggs are quite fragile cells
so the quality of the cells after the um
cell sorting is not really uh the proper
one and also gmp grade flow starting is
needed and it is missed actually right
now but
we as a tool provider offering you two
devices
clinimax prodigy with lp 25
pre-enrichment process and maxcon title
cell sorter which gives you this
opportunity to isolate different tuix
subsets and reach ultra-pure turret
populations
so let's have a look on the
following slides and see how these
devices can help you to
reach your goals
cleaning max prodigy lp25 process
enables you to enrich your cd25
cells
and at the same time help you to label
your t-rex with the proper proper
fluorochromes and then i elude your
t-rex in a special buffers that can be
transported to the max quantitative cell
sorter and then you can start uh sort
your cells to isolate the subpopulation
that you want to reach and also reaching
ultra pure t-rex
and this application
uh is mainly used for autoimmune
diseases for
producing car turrets in organ
transplantation you need to really
isolate a specific antigen
antigen-specific uh t-rex and reaching
ultra-pure t-rex gvhd and in summary
it's really suitable for application
which need ultra-p or t-rex subset and
in this
approach you can reach over 98 persons
uh purity
and
the
isolation part takes like about 10 hours
and expansion as well as i've mentioned
in the previous case as well it depends
really to your protocols and which
approach you want to use and what is
your downstream application and how much
you need to expand yourselves and it can
be vary from 12 to 36 days and the final
cell number is it's again dependent on
the donor and the expansion time but
it's normally needed to really reach 50
times 2 000 times
expansion
as far as title cell sorter is one of
the very uh well-known device for
sorting of t-rex in t-reg therapy field
i would like to talk about it more again
and emphasize on this device and
the
beneficial points and the advantages of
the device that you can really use in
your workflow you can
use title cell sorter with gmp grade
cartridges to reach really like is trial
and close system
no carryover or cleaning is needed it's
plug and play
easily scalable no droplets or
detectable oral cells and sample is
never lost and all can be done in the
cartridges
okay i would like to talk about the
capacity of the cartridges which i know
is really important in the clinical
applications as you have more samples
and you need to save your times and also
be flexible with different volume of the
cells
here i would like to show you that we
have one standard cartridge and the
other model of the cartridge is high
speed cartridge and it's it's an amazing
let's say cartridge that helps you to
save your time especially when you have
high volume of the
sample to start and look liquid flow is
in a standard cartridge for four
milliliters in
an hour but in high speed uh cartridge
you can analyze eight milliliter per
hour is the samples and inputs for both
of them are 10 milliliter and maximum
cell
concentration in a standard cartridge is
50 million per ml and also in high speed
cartridge but what is different is
maximum cell flow rate that in a
standard cartridges you can analyze 55
000 cells per seconds whereas in high
speed cartridges you can analyze 110 000
cells per seconds and as you know and
you can see here you can really like
save times in this way for example in
each sort for in standard cartridge
takes like 2.5 hours whereas in higher
speed cartridge 1.25 hour
per sorting it might takes a time
and regarding to the
turret sorting as they are rare cells
and you need to start with really like
high volume of the samples i can imagine
that high speed cartridge fits perfectly
into your workflow
another aspects of max quantity to sell
sorter which is uh which makes it really
fitting into clinical setting is that uh
sorting happened exclusively in the
fully closed and straight
cartridges and there is no fluids inside
the instruments itself and also
currently it is approved for 10
different
clinical trials phase 1 and 2 and over
200 patient samples sorted with title
cell sorter and also all the consumable
are available in gmp
grade max gmp grade and all the
extensive documentation are available
for all that touches the cells and we
provide you um max 3mp title cartridges
max gmp title running buffers and the
last but not the least that i know might
be very attractive for you is max gmp
fluorescence antibody that we have a
very optimized and complete panel of
antibodies for starting 2x
in this slide i would like to share some
data with you to show you the efficacy
of maxclan title soul sorter inserting
the naive 2x
on the left hand side you can see the uh
analysis of the cells which are
post-product glp-25 process pre-title
cell sorting that in this
graph it shows that we reach 38 percent
pre-enrichment of the t-rex
it was followed by debulking uh
sorting and
max quantitative cell sorter and we
reached 83 percent's uh purity
but as far as we need higher periods
you'll go for ultra pure two eggs we
started another sort of uh purity
sorting
and the final yield shows you that we
reached 98 percent's uh pure naive t-rex
which you can see are positive city 25
and negative for city 127s
t-rex expansion again in the clinical um
great
t-rex expansion as well there are lots
of challenges
miltoni biotech is offering you a
customized solution to automate your
workflow you need to ask our customized
application cap team to design a proper
process for you otherwise we have some
sort of products that helps you to
expand yourself but if you want to
benefit from automation in a closed
system you can contact us and ask for
customized application and our
application people are ready to help you
okay tuberc expansion as well in a
clinical grade needed some component
that i would like to talk about them in
the following slides
i have already talked about a tex-max
medium
in the research site
but as i've mentioned we have the gmp
medium grade as well which contains
pharmaceutical great human serum albumin
and it has optimized formulation widow
or without phenyl and it has qc
functionality tests and every batch and
it's uh filled in flexible bags as well
or you can ask for customized format um
and according to your request our team
property
proper format for you but don't forget
that it is really specialized for
optimal cultivation of human t-cells and
2x
okay you need definitely three more
components to reach very good expansion
of your t-rex max gmp expect 2x bits
it's a simulatory bits that help you to
expand your 2x
and it maintain foxp3 expression in your
cells max gmp rapamycin that you need to
use to inhibit the expansion of the
conventional t cells and also to enhance
the proportion of expanded 2x fox p3
cells in culture
and also max gmp ielts you that you can
see the functionality of this max gmp um
great
cytokines compared to the other
commercial products as well
in these slides i would like to show you
um some like application data
you can see that after
sorting of your cells and title cell
sorter in this experiment will reach
92.7 percent fox p3 positive cells
and cd25 positive cells
14 days culturing in tex max 3mp medium
max gmp expect 2x sketch in the presence
of rapamycin and gmp-il-2
you reach
98.3 positive persons positive cells
for fox p3 and cd25 but don't forget
that turreg expansion
is really donor dependent and depending
to the fact that you are using the
healthy or patient samples depending on
your manual protocols and depending on
the duration of the expansion and all
the components that are present in the
culture play a key role on the expansion
rate of your t-rex
for t-rex analysis you can analyze your
tuberics functionally or phenotypically
and there are some key markers that you
need to uh analyze them during and
the the phenotypical analysis and for
functional analysis we have a specific
t-rex suppressor inspector kit
to analyze your cells properly you need
to use a good
let's say
fellow cytometry device we offer you max
quant analyzer family with different
definitions and models
and i don't want to really talk about
all of them in the details but just to
informing you that we are offering you a
big family of the uh max quan's analyzer
with different uh specification
for phenotypical analysis of t-rex we
have some t-rex detection kits which are
optimized antibody kits with hydrated or
let's say pre-titrated antibodies
developed as a simple one reagent
solution and at the same time you can
benefit from re-affinity recombinant
antibody plus our wild antibody
conjugation which offers you high purity
and lots to lost consistency for greater
reproducibility and you can eliminate a
tedious and cost cfc receptor blocking
the steps because they have one
universal isotope which control
for the convenience and cost saving
and here i would like to tell you that
we can help you to analyze your cells
phenotypically with very
optimized and
flexible panel of antibodies you just
need to contact us
and say
your aim your goal your wish panel and
we help you to optimize your panel
here i can show you like a t-rex surface
marker detection using an eight color
panels
we can help you to even
do the correct gating and designing the
proper panel for your
specific
needs and also staining the
intracellular markers and surface
markers and then the cells from
different resources
and also you can analyze the
functionality of your
t-rex and t-rex suppression and spectra
is a polyclonal stimulus
that are maxi beats coupled to alpha cd3
cd28 and cd2
these maxi bits coupled that coupled
with this alpha cd3 cd28 and cd2 they
assimilate your responder t cells in an
optimized way that they can chloriferate
as you can see here in this illustration
their cells the responder cells
got your simulation
and they spa expanded but in this
part they got this simulation but as far
as the two responder cells are
co-culturing with t-rex and the t-rex
are functional they didn't let the two
responder cells to
be polarified and in this way you can
analyze the functionality of your cells
i really wish for longer time to show
you more application examples and cover
all the aspects of the workflow and all
the
solutions that we have for each steps
but please reach out to us to get more
information at this time i have to
really go to the summary part and
just finish my talk
if you need more information on our web
page you can find our clinical and
research brochures we have different
application note references list we have
like different type of scientific post
stories macs and more
like some
customer reports and you can
have a look at the application page for
the research regulatory t cells clinical
application of regulatory t cells and
getting lots of information about
different devices that i was talking
during my talk and don't hesitate to
contact us the local team and global
team directly to get more information in
each step of your workflow
and with this disclaimer i would like to
finish my talk and say that i'm so
thankful for your attention your
participation thank you again dr mount
hazary for your time today and your
important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor miltoni biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
questions submitted today and during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time take care everyone and
goodbye
you